my guest this week is a professor of
marketing and evolutionary behavioral
scientist and author and now the first
ever three-time although he may think
four time guests on the Rubin report GAD
said welcome back thank you so much for
having me back
it is four times it is four times
technically because you were also on a
panel or exactly right but I was saying
three because only when you're fully
here and fully present now and we can
lock eyes like this for an hour and have
that mind meld does it fully carry so
much having any congratulations on going
independent best of luck yeah it'll be a
huge success so far so good
and I'm thrilled to have you back
because you know how much I enjoy
talking to you and there's just never an
ending here this conversation that we've
been having for quite some time so over
the course of the next hour so I want to
review some of the things we've
discussed because some of these trends
keep bubbling up and then I want to go
into some new territory but I should
start by saying that you're on vacation
right now Hannity though so your glow
you always have that glow the glow is
here in a natural state because I'm in
the Sun I'm from Lebanon yeah and it
only becomes unnatural in the winter of
Montreal and when I turn green yeah so
you live up in Canada so you don't get
the natural sunshine of SoCal but I'm
glad you wrote up Lebanon because that's
where I want to start because the
Olympics are right now and while you're
on vacation you've been pretty much
taking the social media I ATIS and I
tagged you in a tweet about a week ago
where it was that the Lebanese team
would not let the Israeli team on the
bus the first night of the Olympics and
I tagged you in that because you are
Lebanese and we've talked about this a
little bit so first off if we could just
for a couple minutes just review your
history growing up in Lebanon you you
went through some just absolutely
horrific stuff where you and your family
have been through and you are a refugee
and and a brown person and all that now
I've done a lot of talking so just can
you just catch us up on that for the
people that haven't heard of story yeah
I'm up there
Harvick's my mother tongue we were
Lebanese Jews and in 1975 the civil war
broke out which was a profoundly
barbaric civil war and the Jews the Jews
that remained at Lebanon were really
caught in a very very delicate position
where we really needed to leave and so
we were there for the first year the
civil war then left Lebanon and they're
doing a threat of execution subsequently
when we emigrated to Montreal my parents
kept going back to Lebanon back and
forth and on one of their trips back to
Lebanon in 1980 they were kidnapped by
Fatah so not only did we experience the
horrors of the Civil War subsequently
after being safe in Canada
my parents were you know faced new
trials and tribulations on their on a
return trip luckily we were able to I
say we I was actually not involved I was
15 years old the out of my family and
their connections were involved in
rescuing them I think they spent eight
days in captivity some real bad stuff
happened to them but luckily we got them
out and since 1980
no one's been back to o-town yeah so
Fatah for people that don't know is
basically that's the political party of
the Palestinian Authority now okay so I
wanted to just get that out there so
people understand a little bit about
your history and then to link it to the
Olympics you told me privately a really
fascinating story about your brother yes
oh so I have two brothers and a sister
all of whom are much older than me the
next oldest older brother is 10 years
older than me who lives actually in
Southern California
he was a international level judoka judo
player he had been Lebanese champion
three years in a row if memory serves me
right and then he was approached by some
thugs and under the auspices also of
supported by the Lebanese I guess judo
Federation and told that he needed to
retire from judo because you know you
can have Jews you know winning these
competitions and so he didn't want to
obviously retire he saw that he could no
longer stay in Lebanon this is
for the Civil War yeah and so he left to
France to Paris to pursue his studies
and his judo career and so he didn't
really experience the Lebanese civil war
then when we emigrated to Montreal in
1976 the material Olympics were
happening about the Olympics were
happening in Montreal and so then the
Lebanese Federation was willing to
overlook to forgive the fact that he was
a dirty Jew because he was a
international level
you know jhulka and so he represented
Lebanon in the 1976 Olympics of the guys
kicked out of Lebanon incredible he's a
Jew then represents the flag of Lebanon
regrettably I think he lost in the first
round I think to a Bulgarian you could
probably check out on Google or you know
do a search yeah but but that shows you
sort of the hypocrisy of the Middle East
so it's incredible hypocrisy of course
and it really goes to show you and
everyone's screaming about this is about
land it's about land it's about land but
you were Lebanese citizens you were you
were an ethnic religious minority in
Lebanon but other than being Jewish it
had nothing to do with land or it had
literally nothing to do zero with land
so those old hatreds and that's what I
thought was so fascinating about what
happened at the Olympics this week but
basically is getting no coverage so the
Lebanese wouldn't let the Israelis on
the bus then the Israeli judo player
compete with player do they say player
apathetic fighters should go come okay
yeah he he beat an Egyptian often the
Arabs don't even compete when there's an
Israeli involved he wouldn't bow to him
he wouldn't shake his hand after the
Israeli went on and won the bronze a
Saudi Arabian suddenly claimed an injury
out of nowhere to not face an israeli
where these things happen in all these
international tournaments all the time
and i thought this really fits and not
only does it fit your personal story but
it fits a lot of the things we're
talking about all the time because
you've sort of you've been a big
defender of what you call the juice the
evil juice the evil juice the jews now
you're you're an atheist so we've
discussed this before and I've had a few
guests on who does
describe themselves at his atheist but
they still either connected somehow
culturally to Judaism or in the case of
my friend Ali Rizvi he just wrote a book
it's called the eight things Muslim he's
a non-believer but believes that there's
a ethnic attachment to being Muslim can
you describe how that sort of fits in
your worldview yeah so let me if you
take a car a car is defined by many
attributes it's a multi attribute object
its defined by its gas efficiency and a
safety record and it's brand name
right so there are multiple components
that constitute a particular car well
your Judaism is a multi attribute object
right there is an element of religiosity
but even if I exclude that if I say look
I don't believe in the Book of Buddha
stuff there is a cultural element there
is a genetic element the lineage there
is a history history there is cuisine
there so they are meant this Jewish
humor Jewish culture Jewish science so
there are multiple ways by which I could
identify with a group of people the way
people can identify with their favorite
soccer team right and I can belong to
that shared people without necessarily
believing in the religious narrative and
so in that sense I'm an atheist you and
if you look at throughout history most
of the prominent Jews that you could
probably think of who are clearly
defined as Jewish were either
atheist or very strongly agnostic right
I mean Albert Einstein would probably be
the the greatest example of that so
tying this back to everything that's
going on with Israel and as I said you
openly defend Jews which is not thought
of as cool even though Jews are a tight
absurdly tiny minority of 15 million
people left and have been Holocaust it
and programmed and everything else
across the world what is going on here
with this oppression Olympics thing and
everything that we constantly are
fighting against with the left where
it's fairly obvious to me that Jews are
being first thrown under the bus there
the first minority thrown under the bus
and we're seeing that other minorities
now are being thrown under the bus in
the course of the oppression Olympics
because that's how it works you always
have to throw somebody else right to
move yourself higher so what happened
here you know it's amazing because just
in the years that I've been on social
media I've noticed the greater
tense of exhibiting open jew-hatred and
I don't have any empirical data so it's
anecdotal but if I look at the amount of
jus related comments not positive ones
that I received five six seven years ago
versus today there definitely seems to
be a permissiveness that is now seeping
its way into public discourse where it
is okay again to criticize to hate to
point the finger choose and it's not
Israel it's jews let's not make a
mistake it's use so how do you make that
distinction because I know that people
are going to say you know if you defend
Israel's or you say that something's
actually anti-semitic when you're
attacking a group of people it all gets
conflated with with what Israel is you
know I posted a picture on Twitter the
other day of this absurdly tiny piece of
land that's literally smaller than New
Jersey that if you remove the West Bank
at one point it's something like six
miles wide I mean we're talking about
nothing that it for many years had no
natural resources now they've got some
gas or whatever but it's like this focus
on this little place is is just insane
the creation of Israel was a godsend
forgive the term you could say that
right there all the Jew haters yeah
because now they could they could openly
be hateful towards the Jewish people
people but always couch it under the
sort of veneer of no no it's Israel I
love the Jews Jews are really cool
they're funny I love Jerry Seinfeld that
was my favorite show right I just really
hate the Nazi apartheid you know state
of Israel which by the way we should
condemn them because otherwise we're not
fair and balanced so in both despise the
evil Nazi racist apartheid state of of
Israel right by the way Jerry Seinfeld
who at least one of his parents was
Syrian or is Syrian not going to well
for the probably one remaining Jew in
Syria there's probably one or there's
ten letters Egypt or in any of those
places she might might several my
grandparents are originally Syrian Jews
so but anyways and so so if you're in a
kid in your
mother's basement and there is endless
number of in justices and genocides
happening around the world that are
infinitely greater in how grave they are
then whatever is happening in terms of
the dynamic in Israel but yet you choose
to focus on some violation it might have
been a valid one yeah
and the countries above criticism might
say that all the time exactly so it's
not because people write me and say so
are you saying that any criticism of
Israel's automatic of course not yeah
but it's the question is you know you
could be twenty pounds overweight or 200
pounds overweight both people are called
overweight right one is ten times more
overweight than the other yeah so
therefore when you forgive the 250 300
thousand people that have been just
killed in the Syrian war you know who
cares about that stuff but then you
focus on some interaction that happened
between an Israeli soldier and a
Palestinian woman and you're some kid
who's not wearing pants and his parents
on the basement yeah then maybe you're
anti-semitic because your focus should
not necessarily be on that particular
issue if you care so much about
universal justice does this sort of show
you the the general absurdity of
religion in a weird way because to me it
seems like the idea the idea of the
chosen people I could see but first of
all I never liked that phrase I'm
growing up I never liked that phrase cuz
I thought chosen for what I'm no better
than anyone I never felt that in any way
that that was a good thing thing being
thrust upon anyone I never liked that
phrase at all but if you were an
outsider and you go and let's say you
were a believer right and you're an
outsider you go they're the chosen
people well then putting yourselves
above them on the oppression Olympics
make sense because a see they did
something and they're chosen so it
really just becomes this like
self-fulfilling prophecy sorted although
just to clarify at least as I understand
it because I want to ask the rabbi about
the exact meaning of chosen people it's
not how people typically take it to mean
that you're superior or better it's
actually chosen in the sense that God
has chosen you to be pious to lead the
way in your purity so as sort of I'm not
sure how
I'm doing that either but as Sir Francis
Maloney goes right it's actually a
rather tame version of supremacy there
are other religions we won't say which
ones they are that are supremacist but
are not quite as tame in their supremacy
yeah okay so let's let's shift a little
bit Meg and we're not going to spend the
entire summit hour on all the religious
stuff in Islam and all that but it's a
sum
I did not say where's your Aslan decoder
your ass on you ger Dakota are you with
the Kota 5000 yeah where is that then
you don't bring it with you it's in my
brain it's in your brain okay very good
okay so it seems to me that it's very
obvious right now there that and you've
been one of the people really calling
this out that there is a clash of
cultures happening right now and there
we've seen what's happening with the
immigration and the migrants in Europe
and good people good decent people not
big it's not xenophobes not racists are
trying to get a hold of if you see bombs
going off and you see stabbings and
shootings and all of these things how do
we deal with this and whether it's about
purely about religion or cultures or all
of this stuff you've put yourself right
in the middle of this conversation what
do you think and you've seen the way
Canada's change by the way which is
something I wanted asked Matt about
what's going on in Montreal so I'll
start with just E what I call cultural
homo Philly yeah so if you look at how
people choose their mates it turns out
the birds of a feather flock together in
other words if you want a successful
union with someone it's not the
opposites attract all the research shows
that somebody who shares your values
your beliefs your interest you're likely
to have a better Union we tend to choose
dogs that look on average more like us
so there are all sorts of ways by which
is idea of homophily being attracted
someone similar to you manifests itself
and doesn't that somehow seem racist or
narcissist a narcissistic or somehow
your other ring or something right well
maybe maybe but it's true it's what
you're saying it's life yeah okay
people like to band with those who are
similar to them now so then I take this
principle and I apply it at the cultural
level if you are Sweden you're likely
to experience greater success
assimilating people from Denmark and
it's a profoundly obvious and trivial
statement to make then people who are
coming from Yemen not because Yemeni
people are evil and diabolical it's
because there is such a minimal overlap
and their central defining cultural
values then it becomes difficult for
these two cultures to assimilate with
one another to get along with one
another right if you have a messy person
who lives with a very clean person it's
going to result in problems right and so
I argue basically that it doesn't really
take a sophisticated and electoral to
realize that if you take endless
millions of people that almost share
none of the cultural compass that define
Western society it doesn't take much to
predict what's going to happen yeah and
it doesn't make you a racist or a bigot
but the Dalai Lama came out publicly and
said that oh you know we can't allow
Germany to become an Arab country now
how come they didn't go after him the
way they go after Donald Trump all right
he said basically the same thing I've
had on my show a guy by the name of
professor Sally Mansour who's a
practicing Muslim who appeared in front
of the Canadian Parliament saying stop
Islamic immigration he's Muslim he's a
practicing Muslim why is he saying that
is inna seong-ho he's a brown man he's
Indian man well because he realizes that
the cultural values the cultural baggage
that these guys are bringing are not
consistent with ours yeah so how do you
make the moral distinction there by as
someone that wants to do good I'm a firm
believer that most people want to do
good if they can help other people they
want to and then also understand that
there are actual cultural problems and
forgetting culture even there are
economic reasons we know what's
happening in Germany they brought in 1.3
million people even if all of those
people were the most wonderful
assimilated spectacular scientists and
free thinkers ever the strain on the
system in terms of healthcare I saw
something like it was going to cost like
a billion American dollars to just do
dental work on these people which they
are going to get for free that then
creates a hostility towards the
immigrants
how do you it's hard to sort of make
that moral guide right or that follow
that path right so I would say look you
leave a very few select numbers of entry
numbers for people who are truly fleeing
so if we talk about the Middle East or
Syria there are people who are you know
the Yazidi or Iraq and or you know Greek
Orthodox or or Catholics that should be
at the front of the list because they're
the first ones who are going to be
beheaded right so you leave a certain
number of as we when we escaped and came
to Canada there's not as though I'm
anti-immigration or anti refugee or anti
altruism but it doesn't make sense to
allow the types of numbers and precisely
for the reasons that you said forget
about Islam forget about the cultural
thing just pragmatically right how do
you integrate so many people and so I
use two principles from evolutionary
theory when I talk about these points so
there's a principle called kin selection
and evolutionary theory which basically
refers to the idea that you know why do
I jump into a river to save my sons but
not some random other kids
well because my sons share on average
half my genes and so if I save three of
my children from an evolutionary
calculus it actually makes sense if I
sacrifice myself so hold that thought
for a second there's another
evolutionary principle called reciprocal
altruism which is you know why would I
jump and save Dave Rubin who doesn't
share my genes
well you better sell this better so
there you go with this one because
because hopefully if in the future I
have the need for you to save me you
reciprocate it's a form of reciprocal
grooming that we see in other primates
right tit for tat right so now take
these two principles we tend to want to
invest more and those that are
genetically related to us and we tend to
want to invest in those who are likely
to reciprocate in the future now how
does that fit with having Germans
letting in 1.3 million people who
certainly have no genetic link it is
never mind no genetic affiliation right
they don't share any cultural overlap
right and these guys are not going to
reciprocate it's not as though in some
future world as Syria will reciprocate
the kindness
so it's a very parasitic relationship
right we're always expected to
exhibit infinite altruism but never is
that reciprocated from the other camp so
that's actually really fascinating a
couple levels so on one hand you could
look at just the bordering Arab
countries in the Gulf states that are
absurdly wealthy that have what is it
that's doesn't Saudi Arabia of housing
for some remind people I thank so much
sir sir yeah that for all these people
that go to the Hajj every year these
air-conditioned tents that sit empty
probably 90% of the year and they're not
letting anyone in yourself so that's
what you're talking about the altruism
really only works one way so is that a
defect of the West right is this a you
know I keep saying the road to hell is
paved with good intentions that's my
it's an old phrase but it's become my
new phrase because I see it permeating
almost everything right now
well because it's become a form of
secular religion right and the same way
that religion parasitizes your brain so
that you no longer have the capacity to
reason properly you could have other
parasites other parasitic you know ideas
in this case infinite altruism right
praying at the altar of
self-flagellation as I call it right the
West is bad self flagellate let in the
guys who are going to behead us that
makes us then we're somehow good we're
good right so it locally just give you a
great example from Quebec and maybe
eventually we'll move to what's
happening in Canada sure so the Quebec
government is profoundly concerned by
losing its linguistic identity right it
is it is an amongst a sea of
English speakers whether it be the rest
of Canada or the United States and it's
desperate to maintain its linguistic
integrity so in their desperate desire
to maintain French as a dominant you
know reality they let in endless folks
from profoundly disturbing backgrounds
for example take the algerian so the
algeria in 1997 had a war between some
really hardcore Islamist and the
government they wanted to set up a you
know theocratic state they lost the
Islamists lost all those Islamists then
turn to Quebec and say oh refugee
refugee we're being persecuted by the
government they come to Quebec well
guess what happens Quebec says oh you
could say bonjour
c'mon Sava okay you could behead me but
as long as before you behead me
you say sorry and Banjul then everything
is good
so I mean it's I'm being a bit facetious
but it really is that right so it
becomes this this diabolical parasite
that causes people to not be able to
think clearly about trivially obvious
reality yeah what do you make of the
fake moralizing because that to me is
what I see is the biggest problem and
you're calling it the self flagellation
I mean I was on a radio show with a guy
who I've known for a long time and he
was asking me other refugees and I said
look I'm for Refugees as a for
immigration as a general rule all of us
unless we were our ancestors were
brought here as slaves or we were Native
Americans were all refugees or
immigrants of some kind so I understand
that but I could say I just don't know
that we have the systems in place and
the checks in place and we have to
figure some of that out I didn't think
that was grosser racist or anything of
that nature and he kept going on and on
about how he would house them in his
house and bah-bah-bah and I said well
this was on air live I said well you
know if you'd like to have them in your
house I'd be happy to do a little
research for you and let you know and
then suddenly said well my wife I don't
know if my wife would let me know so
it's like this fake moralizing to
somehow make me feel bad like I was a
bad guy just for having an honest
conversation wasn't saying stop the
people I wasn't saying kick anybody out
this fake moralizing and then you turn
it on them and you watch their arguments
usually crumble right it's outrageous
that I'll give you a I did a satirical
piece on one of my truth clips where I
talked about we have to stop dark alley
phobia if you look at the number of
murders per year in Canada it's
astonishingly low now if you look at the
number of murders that are committed in
dark alleys it's almost as high as if it
may be oh right were to hit us again if
most people have the evolved response of
not wishing to walk down the dark alley
and that's very racist and gross and
bigoted against dark alleys right our
brains have evolved to calculate
statistical regularities I know that
when I walk down a dark alley four young
men are likely to be more dangerous than
four elderly women that's not because
I'm a just right because I'm sexist
because on average young men are more
dangerous than old ladies even though
most young men are
so that's the interesting piece so the
the fake moralizing actually makes you
remove a piece of yourself that we've
evolved to understand why I call these
people as you know the ostrich Brigade
right astrati Brigade and then naturally
lobotomized
you